CRITICAL.
>> Bret: WE MAY HAVE MANCHIN
UPDATES ON A NUMBER OF ISSUES.
CHAD PERGRAM ON THE HILL.
THANKS.
PRESIDENT BIDEN IS RESTRICTING
TRAVEL FROM INDIA OVER THAT
COUNTRY'S CORONAVIRUS SURGE.
BEFORE HE WAS ELECTED, PRESIDENT
BIDEN CRITICIZED PRESIDENT TRUMP
XENOPHOBIA ON THE SAME DAY THAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP ANNOUNCED A
TRAVEL BAN TO CHINA BECAUSE OF
THE VIRUS.
STATE DEPARTMENT CORRESPONDENT
RICH EDSON HAS A SITUATION
REPORT TONIGHT.
>> CITING EXTRAORDINARILY HIGH
COVID-19 CASE LOADS AND MULTIPLE
VARIANTS CIRCULATING THERE, THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION ANNOUNCED
THE UNITED STATES WILL RESTRICT
TRAVEL FROM INDIA STARTING NEXT
WEEK.
>> WE, AS A COUNTRY, HAVE MADE A
COMMITMENT TO THE PEOPLE OF
INDIA TO SUPPORT THEM.
>> A YEAR AGO, THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN ACCUSED THEN CANDIDATE
BIDEN OF CALLING THE CHINA
TRAVEL BAN XENOPHOBIC.
BIDEN ALSO TWEETED THEN QUOTE
BANNING ALL TRAVEL FROM EUROPE
OR ANY OTHER PART OF THE WORLD
WILL NOT STOP IT, REFERRING TO
THE VIRUS' SPREAD.
BIDEN'S CAMPAIGN SAID HIS
REFERENCE TO TRUMP'S XENOPHOBIA
WAS RELATED TO THE FORMER
PRESIDENT SCAPEGOAT OTHERS, NOT
HIS CHINA TRAVEL BAN.
BIDEN'S CAMPAIGN ALSO SAID HE
BACKS TRAVEL RESTRICTIONS THAT
EXPERTS SUPPORTED.
IN THE OPENING DAYS OF HIS
ADMINISTRATION, BIDEN TIGHTENED
INTERNATIONAL TRAVEL
RESTRICTIONS, REVERSING A LATE
ORDER FROM PRESIDENT TRUMP WHO
HAD RELAXED THEM.
>> INDIA IS NOW ON THAT LIST.
WHERE CROWDED HOSPITALS ARE
TURNING AWAY PATIENTS, EVEN IF
THEY MANAGE A SPOT, OXYGEN
SUPPLIES ARE OFTEN SPENT.
>> MY FATHER'S DEAD BODY WAS
LYING THERE.
WHEN I ASKED WHAT HAPPENED,
THERE WAS NO ONE TO INFORM US,
AND LATER WHEN I SPOKE TO A
NURSE THERE, SHE TOLD ME THAT
THEY RAN OUT OF OXYGEN SUPPLY IN
THE MORNING.
>> NEARLY 400,000 NEW DAILY
COVID CASES BREAKING GLOBAL
RECORDS THERE ARE MEDICINE AND
TESTING SHORTAGES.
A THRIVING BLACK MARKET FOR
SUPPLIES AND OVERWHELMED CREAM
THAT TORE I CAN'T.
THIS WEEK THE STATE DEPARTMENT
REVIEWED LEVEL FOUR WARNING FOR
INDIA.
URGING AMERICANS NOT TO TRAVEL
THERE DEPARTMENT OFFICIALS ARE
ALSO OFFERING FAMILY MEMBERS OF
AMERICAN DIPLOMATS IN INDIA THE
OPTION TO LEE THE COUNTRY.
THE U.S. GOVERNMENT SAYS IT IS
SENDING $100 MILLION WORTH OF
CODE AID.
>> INDEPENDENTIA, ASSISTANCE TO
THE UNITED STATES, WHEN OUR
HOSPITALS WERE STRAINED EARLY IN
THE PANDEMIC.
THE UNITED STATES IS DETERMINED
TO HELP INDIA IN ITS TIME OF
NEED.
>> THE FIRST SHIPMENTS OF OXYGEN
CYLINDERS, DIAGNOSTIC KITS AND
MASKS ARE ARRIVING IN INDIA.
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION HAS
ALSO PLEDGED TO RELEASE
60 MILLION DOSES OF ASTRAZENECA
VACCINES TO OTHER COUNTRIES AS
THEY BECOME AVAILABLE.
THAT VACCINE IS NOT APPROVED FOR
USE IN THE UNITED STATE